yes sir have you been following the news
on project veritas no i have not
i know i i've been i've been bad i've
been behind i've been traveling so much
lately it's just
sleeping i'm gonna rock this guy i know
i know i i really i just haven't been
sleeping is the thing that's the issue
so the story from project veritas they
uh they suit the new york times right
oh snap and they won a major victory
really the case is not over
oh boy but so so i think james mentioned
that there's only been like in the past
80 years something like eight lawsuits
that have made it past a motion to
dismiss
here's what happens wait eight lawsuits
against the new york times
okay there's something called anti-slap
strategic lawsuits against public
participation when you sue
a prominent news organization or public
figure you have a
it's called an actual malice standard
meaning you had to have known
what you said was false or what you
wrote was false
which is almost impossible to do very
difficult i think we've talked about
this before you really can't prove that
somebody knew what they were saying
how do you read their mind it's really
difficult to prove intent however in
general
if you can get past a motion to dismiss
you can go through their messages
and you can put them under oath which
veritas now will be able to do
here's the oh clear their inboxes at the
new york times
they've been instructed to preserve all
dating communications it would be did
they smash their cell phones with
hammers and delete ever
all 30 000 emails i'm sorry you want to
know what the best part about this
lawsuit is
tell me the defense the new york times
had
to get james o'keefe's lawsuit dismissed
was that their factual news articles are
actually
unverifiable opinions really really so
they said the quiet part loud i love it
yeah
it was it was a defense they basically
said when we called project veritas
deceptive
and you know said these things about him
those were just our writers
unverifiable opinions and are thus not
actionable
and the judge said seems to me that if
you're stating something is a
factual news piece but your inter your
reporters interject their opinions
you should be required to tell people it
was an opinion piece but wait
tim if if it's the opposite of
fact news what is that what's that
called opinion uh the opposite
fate there's another fake fake word fake
fake some kind of
fake news news which has been faked what
is
unbelievable cnn up i never thought i'd
live to see the day i know
this this no this is serious i mean
project veritas
may have if they win and i think they
they will based on this preliminary
ruling it sounds really good
this could set precedent that could last
for a hundred years that would be
beautiful
yeah i really did not i did not agree
with um
no oh never mind sorry i was about to
make a comment about the new york times
oh this is new york times or is the cnn
sorry i'm all over the place right now
yeah i didn't agree with new york times
uh you know opinion pieces on the uh
hollow tomorrow either
really weird going back along those
opinions yeah yeah those opinion pieces
were pretty bad
that they got pulitzer prizes for for
their opinions
the pulitzer prize and opinion sorry so
the the way the way the news has
typically worked and i've talked to
lawyers about lawsuits as they say tim
i'm sorry they smeared you there's
nothing you can do it's an opinion
and i was like so you mean to tell me if
someone writes an article and says like
ian
is you know far right or whatever they
they can publish it in a news article
and just say ian crossland a far right
commenter
even though there's no factual basis to
that and they're like it's their opinion
yeah and i was like hold on if a news
organization is claiming they're
reporting facts
doesn't matter that phrase is an opinion
and i'm like
how is this the way things work yeah
veritas sues
and the judge said if it's in a if it's
a fact-based news story
stands to reason you have to tell people
if it's actually an opinion piece when
you put opinions in it
that changes the whole game yeah so like
if they were to say something which is
objectively verifiable so if they were
to say like sheamus coughlin has an iq
below 85 and i sued
well they would win because that's
actually true but um if they make so i'm
curious if they make
objective comments about a person beyond
far right or far left right because
these terms can be used any way you want
to use them
when where is the line drawn with
opinion so if you so for example if you
were to say something like that like
this person is
is is stupid or this per like something
where there's a set standard though or
you like made a comment about someone's
iq but in a disparaging way but that's
something that could actually be
verified would that be opinion or have
you like sort of trespassed into the
area of fact
it's it's actually really crazy what
constitutes opinion and what constitutes
fact
so saying like uh shane sheamus coughlin
did a backflip you know uh off
off tim's deck to the ground yeah i said
you did something that's a fact
yeah it is if i said something like
sheamus coughlin
cheated at a game of chess that's an
opinion
but hold on a second you can there are
objective standards for whether a person
cheats at chess no
first of all i don't know how to play
right but so you know that i cheated
and so but but so i shouldn't say
necessarily it's an opinion it's
arguable
so i went through this with with a
lawyer over over a really old piece
and it's basically like well what does
cheated mean define cheated
like broke the rules or changed the
rules to benefit himself
or in some way took an action unbecoming
of the traditional
it's like white supremacist what's
defined white supremacist
uh i would say trump supporter the point
so if you call someone a white
supremacist it's actually
it's a non-actionable opinion really
yeah so i knew that that was true with
labels like extremist i was unaware that
calling someone a white supremacist
is like just a matter i knew it was
oftentimes just used as an opinion and
no one was really using an objective
definition but my understanding was
that's an actual label here's the issue
or like far right dude i'm so old i
remember when you had to be conservative
in order to be considered far right
crazy right so you uh
there was an article that came out a
while ago i was talking to a lawyer
about it they called someone a white
supremacist
and they said define white supremacist
and i said well i believe the academic
definition is
an individual who believes the white
race is superior whoa whoa whoa whoa
that's not the academic definition what
the academic definition is about
whiteness and privilege
what yeah that's journalism i mean
that's i'm sorry
that's college universities they say
white supremacy is the structure of
dominant racial hierarchies and society
which could include
asians or whatever and so they change
the definition so if you go into court
and say your honor he called me this and
it's verifiably false
the individual will say no look here's
here's how we define it here's how
everyone believes
it and because the media accepts the
alternate definition
opinion interesting unverifiable and so
but and then of course yeah they're not
required to define their terms
what if i was like sheamus coughlin
who's
cartoons bore millions of people
a month would that be an opinion well
but that's a fact
everybody just watches and they just
have their eyes half closed like their
opinion because that
[Laughter]
but if i'm like sheamus coughlin who's
white who's racial supremacist
white skin then that's a fact or that's
awesome no it's an opinion no if you
call me
an opinion a statement of fact would be
ian crossland
threw a baseball at a baseball oh and it
was either true or false
right but the other ones are this is ian
crossland has a weak [ __ ] arm
is an opinion ian crosslin who has a
weak [ __ ] arm
threw a pathetic pitch at a baseball
game these all sound like opponents to
me all of these sounds unless you didn't
actually not wrong baseball yeah
your opinion your opinions on the money
yeah
it's just it's crazy that so
i want to avoid getting into getting
into dangerous territory with youtube
because i want to make sure this is a
conversation people can hear
but saying someone did something isn't
always a statement of fact which is
weird
like like saying ian crossland cheated
at a game of magic the gathering could
be opinion could be
that's dangerous could be wow so if you
were like you got caught and everyone
saw you sliding cards in your deck or
something
or i could be like i saw him shuffle
that one way and i say
in my expert opinion that was a cheating
move or for instance there's a there's a
move in magic this is a good example
this is a deck game where you shuffle
cards right for those that aren't
familiar
there was something going on where
people would after so you can shuffle
your opponent's deck to prevent them
from cheating
you could say you can cut their deck so
pros would hand their deck to the other
player the other player would shuffle it
and hand it back
there was one thing people would do
where they would shuffle it but then
keep the last card and throw it on top
of the deck
and they would see the bottom card was
in fact a not good card
then the next turn the player would draw
the bad card and so they said that was
cheating others argued that's not
cheating
you can cut the deck any way you want
information that's revealed because the
card is visible is not
cheating but hold on but you would
actually so but it would only be opinion
if that was what you were referring to
as cheating if you were referring to
something as cheating which is
objectively agreed upon by everyone who
plays the game as being against the
rules then it would be a statement of
fact no
this is where the problem comes in that
apparently opinion or fact has a lot to
do with whether or not large
large enough amounts of people agree
with a certain definition interesting
oh right so if i said you know like
what's something everyone agrees with if
you
a a name you could call somebody that
meant something objective to every
person which is hard to find
ian crossland is a x and everyone's like
oh and x is very clearly this thing
yeah then it would be like well if he's
not then you made that up the problem is
not everyone agrees on what things are
which makes it weird honey is sweet
and that could be a fact but not
everyone's going to taste sweetness when
they taste honey it is
that i think would be a fact because the
high sugar content there's so many
people
but think about people saying things
like male and female don't exist uh oh
right that's i mean that is objectively
not that is an
anti-factual statement that's just that
is faith that's the problem
but of course but yeah i agree that
generally it's it's a matter of
consensus it shouldn't be
so like yes practically speaking i mean
there are facts there are moral truths
which are objective
but we operate in a culture where many
people believe many different things and
so of course
there we don't have this sort of thing
like hegemonic narrative that we might
have surrounding gender that we
did in a time where things made a little
bit more sense with respect to our
sexual politics this is interesting
think about religion it's a really good
really good context
like uh how how how is the pope defined
like
in terms of his position yeah he's the
figure of christ
so imagine someone who's not religious
would say that's that's fake that's not
true it's not true
so then how could you prove defamation
based on that so but here is where you
do get into a matter of fact so if you
were to say like
if a non-religious person is to to say
that like they don't believe the
pope is you know the successor of peter
and chris vicker on earth
that's one thing but then if they were
if they were to say like catholics
do not teach that the pope is christ's
spirit
right now you're talking about something
that like we can the first i i believe
it is the fact that the pope is christ's
vicar on earth
but if we're getting into something that
everyone agrees is factual you just look
at what the church teaches and if you're
saying the church teaches acts when it
objectively teaches why
then you are lying and so this is
something that happened like
joe biden was repeatedly referred to
i've said this before on the show but he
was repeatedly referred to by the media
as a practicing catholic
despite the fact that he actually does
not meet the criteria for what is
considered a practicing catholic based
on the definition that the catholic
church sets because one of the
conditions is you have to give full
ascent to catholic teaching which joe
biden
objectively does not but in the end
that's exactly it that's
a non-catholic he does enough and
they're like oh he seems like he's
practicing they don't even know what the
word
they don't know the word practice and
catholic means exactly but practicing
catholic so if they were to say like
he is a a devout person or a holy man
well those are
those are more subjective but practicing
catholic is a technical term it's not a
subjective label of identity
now what if what if someone said in an
article ian crossland comma
who is objectively factually the
antichrist
comma was seen shopping for a new pair
of jeans today
total opinions yeah well yes it's it's
it's a faith-based thing they can't say
you're lying so then here's the question
though
are you allowed to throw around words
like objectively if you're acknowledging
that you're only speaking an opinion you
are
what it's the weirdest thing like
is objectively a white supremacist
that's just opinion
yes because define white supremacist
i told you if you have a critical race
theory definition of white supremacist
then yes ian is new
[Laughter]
and of course the trade-off the
trade-off that they have to come to
terms with but
won't is that when words become so
subjectively defined they no longer
carry the same weight
so for years and years and years the
word racist was thrown around like it
was nothing
and then probably around the time the
2016 election came around this is not an
original observation other people have
said this
they realized that the word racist just
wasn't cutting it anymore so you'll
notice like it was right around 2017
when they started calling everyone white
supremacists instead
because it's a much more objective
sounding term than racist and also it's
one that can only apply to white people
or people who are in favor of this
structure of whiteness or whatever you
would call it
um and now that seems to have lost all
meaning so i think the next term they've
sort of moved towards
is is incitement to violence right like
oh if you agree with what trump said or
did or you promote his movement that is
incitement towards violence and that's
something they've sort of been doing for
a long time
critical theorists have done this oh if
you disagree with trans ideology then
you are inciting violence against trans
people because hate crimes occur against
them and that's the result of the fact
that you're creating a culture of hatred
etc but
it's such a it's it's so easy to make
that argument for any group of people
for example i could say well veterans
have a very high suicide rate so you
know criticizing u.s foreign policy
probably makes a lot of them feel
horrible about their experience overseas
so you're contributing to their suicide
rate you can play these same games with
any group you want
so imagine a journalist emails you and
they're like hey sheamus you want to
just get some
some comments from you real quick about
the story we're working on delete
is what i do just a real quick question
would you be in favor of you know say
people pooling their resources to try
and
improve technology towards newer cooler
energy tech like fusion sheamus supports
the green new deal
and then they would write hold on you're
like oh that sounds good then they would
write
sheamus coughlin comma a proponent of
the green new deal comma and you and you
would say that's not true i never
supported that
black we asked him in email if he was in
favor of
supporting green new technology said yes
so we called him a proponent of the
great new deal which should be fair that
is the one
left-wing policy i do support the
agreement we can't we can't afford not
to have a green nude deal right now
that's the best part because you just
said that you can never sue someone who
claims you're proponent of the green new
deal even though i'm just hashtag jk
doesn't matter really yeah because that
does not hold up in a court of law jokes
dude this is a new meme if somebody
wrote
sheamus coughlin of freedom tunes who is
a proponent of the green new deal
said today that blah blah blah if you
sued they would show that clip where you
said
it's the one that i actually agree on
and the judge is going to be like i
think a reasonable person can conclude
you were joking
but you can't hold them responsible you
can't expect the media to be reasonable
people so we're going to let them off
the hook here
there's a possibility that they'll say a
reasonable person would have understood
the joke and thus they shouldn't have
but i think actually a reasonable judge
would say you can't just
assume someone understands your intent
that's hilarious if you say something
and someone takes it literally so
everything everyone has ever joked about
really could just be
literal oh yeah and the issue what about
when it becomes cultural enforcement as
to whether or not you hold institutions
credible based on what they say some of
the questions like what if i'm playing a
character in a movie
does does jeff goldblum actually believe
life will find a way
so the issue that says to the actual
malice standard if there's a clip of you
and you say something like the green new
deal is the best i absolutely am in
favor of this and it turned out to be
him now you take it said about you too
oh of course but i but i i like the
the real green new deal not the aoc
green new deal which is a cult manifesto
so i actually do like the idea of
infrastructure investment and new
technologies
i don't like aoc's version which is some
kind of weird cult manifesto about
equity and healthcare and paying people
who don't want to work
that's garbage nonsense but before the
greenwood
now we're getting into well she's the
boss dude she's the boss so point it
come on
until then listen if someone writes a
story about you saying you support the
green new deal
and they see a clip from a movie of you
saying it
you can't prove actual malice because
they'll say look
i realize after the fact he doesn't but
at the time i genuinely thought it was
true based on
what if you kill someone in a movie and
they say a known murderer
we're actually not that far from that
happening though is the problem
what about actual malice standard oh
come on
something's wrong they knew that i know
so you could have just gotten the clip
so i'm sure i'm sure there are some
lawyers who might have like listen this
is this is mostly just based off my
experience i'm not a lawyer
my understanding is the challenge is
proving actual malice meaning
if ian says sheamus did something
sheamus has to prove ian
knew beforehand what he was saying was
false if someone says
here's the clip we saw of sheamus
shooting a rocket launcher into a
building full of nuns
then people would be like well a
reasonable person might conclude that
didn't happen
well hold on but can we now say tim
poole who falsely accused sheamus of
shooting a rocket launcher under a group
of nuns who supported
known he calls himself a journalist and
he spread the fake news
kid so what about ed norton can we say
that he is a white supremacist
you call anyone white's premise i guess
but could you call him a neo-nazi is
neo-nazi and actually an actual defined
term
neo-nazi it's opinion what if you say
like curb stomp somebody killed them
because he did it in a movie
i think you should choose to portray a
known nazi
or what if you don't what do you have to
say here's malice listen listen here's
what it ultimately comes down to
whether or not the judge thinks you're
being reasonable or absurd
the problem is with times v sullivan you
have an actual malice standard which
means
knowing that what you're saying is false
that's a really hard thing to prove yes
extremely difficult
so the new york times fought project
veritas in a ridiculous way
saying our fact-based news it was
actually unverifiable opinion and thus
is is not actionable and the judge was
like yo this is this is not an opinion
section
so what you're saying is taken as fact
by most people it doesn't matter
this is this is the importance of the
veritas ruling they're basically saying
your opinions are purported as facts
because the new york times
therefore you lose the protections of
you know that of the opinion standard
wow okay but the nyt
of course is saying actually we
are as a matter of fact opinion
journalists no that was their defense
and then the judge responded the new
york times responded that their
fact-based news article about veritas
was actually unverifiable opinion
ooh and the judge then said okay
while typically opinions you can't sue
for someone's opinion
you put them in a fact-based news
article if i say
so this is where it gets interesting
this article is 100
fact ian crossland is a lying
thief yeah then they can be like that's
actually your opinion
if i said this is my opinion ian crosson
is a lying thief then they can't sue me
and if you do a fact-based article with
99
facts and then one opinion the entire
article becomes an opinion yes
if this and it must be labeled as such
okay so this is why veritas is so
important
because in the past when i've talked
about libel suits every lawyer says
it's an opinion you can't sue and i'm
like they straight up accuse me of doing
a thing
no it's an opinion murdered orphans but
you can't define some of these terms
like
causing hurt or violence or incitement
all of these things are interpretable
so you can't win with this new ruling
changes the game
veritas open the doors so here's a
question what if you're so you mentioned
that the article can be 99 fact based
and
if it's one like snopes would sign off
on all of it but if there's one part
which is opinion
now the whole thing is an opinion piece
but has to be labeled opinion but
okay but what if the opinion is real
like what if you're listing facts
and then at the end you're like yes this
did happen there was this scandal with
the biden administration blah blah and
then at the end you're like i
enjoy grapes they taste good and it's an
obvious opinion
or like if at some point articles
something comes up which is your opinion
but isn't
quite related maybe you're setting up
the story but everything else is
fact-paced now the whole thing is an
opinion piece and i can say whatever i
want
fascinating hold on you can't say things
you know to be false are my cartoons
opinion
or did those happen i don't know dude
you make a good point because i'm pretty
tired right now
just like movies what was joe biden what
was your latest one
joe biden joe biden stutter please check
that out if you're watching
so i don't know if you guys know this
but joe biden it's not that his brain
isn't functioning well and he's not fit
to be the leader of the free world
he actually has a stutter because that's
how stuttering works yeah
so i did a video on joe biden's speech
therapy class i think you guys are
really going to enjoy it he gets the
stutter worked out it's
it's it's just uh gut busting laugh fest
yeah
yes laugh fest from start to end i did a
video of him in math class as well
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you